katrina is in detroit hi katrina how can
we help
hey super nervous to talk to you guys um
my question is
i recently just got engaged and i would
like to start planning for
our wedding but the problem is is i'm a
hot nest
and in debt so i want to be responsible
while still trying to pay off debt and
not get further into debt but also still
plan a good
wedding good for you so any tips for
advice for trying to get a good budget
number
and how to move forward as well as
talking to my now fiance of how
we want to tackle debt after we get
married okay
what do you make a year around 70.
what does he make a year around 30. okay
and uh how much hot mess dad have you
got
uh 105. and that's in what
uh a little bit of everything hospital
credit cards
what's the big one student loan student
loans how much
78 78 how much you owe in the car
no car no car okay so credit card
student loans and other miscellaneous
crap is the other
uh 20 some odd thousand dollars yep
okay how old are you
27. i had to think about it what do you
do for a living i'm sorry
say that again you're how old 27 27 okay
27.
okay what do you do for a living
research your researcher okay okay good
yeah
okay so what do you think
the budget ought to be for the wedding
you're paying for 100 of it right
correct okay the two of you are mom and
dad aren't helping yes
correct okay i was thinking around 20
but as soon as i start thinking towards
20 i'm like that's a student loan i
could pay off
so i wanted to get a firm good number
but i can just like this is what we're
planning
we're just going to think [ __ ] sunk on
it and this is what it is
and then just move forward from there
all right
the average wedding in america last year
was 28
000. means that
a considerable number of people spent
more than that and a considerable number
of people spent a lot less than that
the average household income in america
last year was right around
60 000. so the typical family is
spending
a maximum or an average of half of their
annual income
on a wedding but they don't have a
hundred and five thousand dollars worth
of debt hanging over their head
either necessarily and some of those mom
and dad are paying for it so we have to
factor all of that stuff in but that's
just some numbers to keep into
consideration
okay got a lot of young people in my
building here
a lot of them getting married every year
while they're trying to get out of debt
so they face the exact same equation you
have
and i have personally attended many many
many
wonderful weddings in the 10 000 and
under range
okay perfect so i'm making this up i'm
just throwing out some
numbers there so i threw out 28 i threw
out 10
you threw out 20. you made you got a
household income when you're married of
a hundred
but you got a hundred and five thousand
dollars hanging over your head so that's
affecting this decision the beauty of
your question is once you make this
decision
you set a wedding budget you stick to it
a full breakdown you run a wedding like
it's a project
for research okay and then you can stick
to it it's not going to randomly happen
in other words in other words if you say
we're going to spend uh twelve thousand
five hundred dollars
i don't care i just made that number up
then you have to decide okay how much on
the reception
how much on the videographer uh how much
on the location
uh how much are we gonna put into the
how many groomsmen and uh bridesmaids uh
and gifts and uh you know you gotta you
kind of
line item out this budget because your
biggest item in most weddings is the
reception
budget-wise i've i've i've been involved
in the background
way in the background uh of three ramsey
weddings
uh in the last few years and but we did
run them on a budget and we did run them
like a project
and um because that's the only way dad's
putting his freaking money in there
so um but the whole point is is you you
do all this and then it takes the
pressure off
because we're going to spend x number of
dollars on the dress which means you're
not going to spend 2x
and you don't have to make all these
ambivalent stress-based decisions over
and over and over again once you make
the one decision
does that make sense completely so i
think your 20 is a little high
but not way high i don't think you're
crazy
and once you make the decision i don't
want to be once you make that decision
have some peace with yourself yeah right
you know you tap out on other people's
expectations because some people are
going to think you spent too much some
people don't think you didn't spend
enough and it's not their dead gum
wedding
i like that and there's there's
dave help me with this um and katrina
will benefit from the conversation
i i feel this tension which is she owes
105
000 bucks man you got to get this thing
taken care of and the math part of me
says
go to the justice of the peace work
really hard to get your debt paid off
and then throw a big party in a couple
years
then there's another side of me that
says we have stripped our culture
of every sort of important
heritage ritual we've just sucked the
soul out of our culture
and i would say no if you're gonna if
you're gonna do something right
do a wedding upright yeah because you're
gonna do it once you're gonna do it big
and it's
gonna be something that you it's gonna
be a touchstone for the rest of your
life
help me find some wisdom in between
those two things i think you're exactly
right
okay and so the point is you don't go
crazy you're not trying to make a
reality show out of this dead gum thing
right on the one hand
but now if someone calls and says uh
look we're bound in the tournament we
both just want to do the jp
we're just going to get we're going to
go to the preacher's office and and get
this done
i'm not going to be mad at you for doing
that that's your choice right but i also
don't want to say as your financial
advisor you have to do that
because otherwise you're unwise okay
because part of personal finance is
this is a milestone and she needs a ring
and she needs a wedding and she needs a
broad address you know and and there's a
milestone here
and there's a celebration around this
historical precedent for
for as long as there have been as long
as there have been weddings they've been
a big deal right you know there you go
right
in funerals right where's the funerals
and births i mean these are the tuning
forks of life they
they reset your head and so i think you
need to have a wedding personally
i i would i mean if you were my child i
might one of my grown kids that came to
me i'd say you need to spend something
on it
but let's not go hog wild i'm kind of my
head just the math that we've all
bounced around katrina
i'm bouncing between 10 and 15 in my
head right now
that makes sense but if you come back
and say you know we talked about it
we're going to do seven
i'm cool with that or we're going to do
17. i'm cool with that but what i do
want you to do is i want you to set that
number
pay cash for it pay cash for it be free
after that because you're going to say
you know a budget that you set
and are in control of the number then
sets you free to make a lot of decisions
on what you're
not going to do you're not going to
overspend you know
this is not an academy award motion
picture we need a few videos
hey katrina does this guy like you
yes a lot i hope so you know
a lot uh he's a good guy
so i don't want you to walk into your
wedding as though you
are the ball and chain here financially
i want you to walk in with your head
held high he has agreed to take you and
all of you
yep and then you're all going to work on
this debt together if you walk in
already ashamed of who you are in your
financial position
that's going to start your marriage off
a step down and then you're going to
have this weird inequity thing that's
going to go on it's going to rattle
around through your
relationship for years to come walk in
with your head held high you put all the
money on the table
made some mistakes but i am willing to
own that and we're going to attack them
and it's in the past the rearview mirror
is smaller than the windshield that's
right that's right but go in with your
head held high he loves you and he's
committed to you and all of you and
y'all gonna do this thing together
yeah you're awesome thank you for
calling in that's a really good question
to talk through
um and and you know i've just watched
our culture strip it all away
and and well i mean i've had people come
in and go
my wife's gonna sell her diamond ring
for the debt snowball and i'm like no
right
but it's even further like if it's a
forty eight thousand dollar diamond ring
we'll talk about but i mean if it's a 40
if it's a typical
you know diamond ring for no you keep
your dadgum ring
it doesn't ten thousand dollars out of a
hundred when you make a hundred doesn't
change this equation much by the way
correct correct but there's something
about knocking down
i don't know this is where i can get off
the rails there's something about
knocking down grandma's house
so we can cram two tall and skinnies on
that little lot so we all feel good what
have you been driving around nashville
i'm just there's something about
heritage man and um
just finding that balance that wisdom
balance yeah i'm with you
i agree this is the ramsay show